black leaders have really prioritized
the integration of political
institutions with the goal of closing
racial and economic gaps and at least in
terms of electing more blacks to office
they've had a good deal of success on
this front by the early 1980s major U.S
cities with large black populations
Cleveland to Detroit to Chicago's
Philadelphia's and so forth had elected
black Mayors almost all of whom pushed
for bigger government and for special
treatment for blacks
since 1970 the number of black elected
officials has grown from fewer than 1500
to more than ten thousand in this
country including of course a black
president
the problem is that all this political
clout
never really paid off economically for
the black poor
which is what we were told would happen
you look at how the black underclass
fared in these black run cities
Coleman Young's Detroit in the 1970s
Marion Barry's Washington DC in the
1980s sharp James is Newark New Jersey
in the 1990s these black Mayors created
unbeatable political machines
in the name of helping the black poor
yet the poor became more impoverished on
their watch
in an era of increasing black political
clout and affirmative action
the black underclass lost ground
both in absolute terms and relative to
the white underclass in the 1970s and
80s and even into the 1990s the poorest
blacks in America saw their incomes
decline at more than double the rate of
the poorest whites in America
in the wake of the war on poverty black
labor force participation declined black
unemployment rates Rose and the black
nuclear family disintegrated
between the 1960s and the 1990s the
proportion of black children living with
both parents fell from two-thirds to
one-third
the pre-1970 era shows that what's
needed more than political saviors
racial preferences wealth redistribution
schemes is economic growth and
opportunity
tight labor markets are more beneficial
than affirmative action
having a black man in the home is more
important than having one in the White
House
a few years ago I wrote a column in the
Wall Street Journal on the prevalence of
violent crime in poor black
neighborhoods
and in the column I used to quote from
Martin Luther King
who once told a black congregation do
you know that Negroes are 10 of the
population in St Louis and responsible
for 58 of the crimes
King said we've got to face that
we've got to do something about our
moral standards
he said we know that there are many
things wrong in the white world
but there are many things wrong in the
black world too
we can't keep on blaming the white man
there are things we must do for
ourselves
after the column ran a number of readers
contacted the paper and accused me of
making up the quote
which comes from a 1961 Harper's
magazine profile of King by James
Baldwin of all people
some readers apparently just couldn't
believe that the nation's most prominent
civil rights leaders used to speak this
way about problems in the black
community and the role of personal
responsibility I'm not arguing that
blacks should disengage
politically my point is that political
power and political clout does not
automatically lead to Upward Mobility
for a group and that's a a case that's
been proven not just with black history
but with the history of many other
groups
who Who Rose economically first and
engaged in politics later and that has
been the more typical pattern for group
Rising a minority group rising from from
poverty to Prosperity so so blacks
political success is not something that
um
I that has automatically translated into
economic success and and and yet that is
what the Civil Rights leadership has
been focused on uh primarily since 1965.
the thinking was that
um we got the Voting Rights pass act uh
the Voting Rights Act passed and if we
can just get more of Our Own in office
the rest will take care of itself and I
went through that history of black
Mayors and poverty rates to show that
the rest has not taken care of itself